mother hasn't worked for years
he is also unemployed and has a family
to look after
at 29 years old he says young people
like him are growing increasingly
despondent about the lack of job
opportunities in South Africa
we are getting irate if we aren't
already we are getting frustrated with
what is happening and what we are seeing
we are really getting or we are already
up to here with the promises that have
never been met not even one his mother
is worried I wish that government would
actually take this very serious because
it's driving our youth to depression
depression that is leading to drug
addiction
nearly three decades after the end of
white minority rule in South Africa most
of those feeling marginalized and
economically excluded are poor and black
critics blame the high unemployment rate
on a number of factors Global events the
pandemic and Corruption South Africa has
one of the most unequal Societies in the
world and the gap between the rich and
poor is growing millions are trapped in
poverty high levels of unemployment here
don't make things easier
some people think the ruling African
National Congress party is not listening
to young people the average age of that
cabinet has shifted from 58 to 60. this
shows you that you have a country that
is being led by people who have no stake
in the future making decisions about
their future this is a cabinet that is
given so much power and authority to
decide on behalf of the future of these
young people
many desperate and discouraged young
South Africans say the government needs
to seriously address Unemployment
otherwise they'll be forced to remain
idle and unproductive
haramatasa Al Jazeera Johannesburg